when you were coming up were there guys
and the only reason i'm asking is
because sometimes in business there's a
lot of people that are here these guys
all from across the world you know got
people here from netherlands qatar here
all across the country
sometimes you're coming up and there are
some guys that are better than you maybe
you fought somebody that had the ability
to be a champion one day maybe get at
your level one day and you kind of saw
them drift away
was there any instances like that where
you saw some guys that could be fighters
but they kind of uh made some mistakes
and they
you know nothing ended up happening with
them we don't know about their stories
yeah i do what were some of can you not
not specific stories but if you don't
mind sharing a couple examples there was
one guy i um
there's a documentary called fightville
it follows me since i was a young
fighter an amateur fighter kind of shows
my journey to the ufc but the name that
comes to mind when you're talking about
guys who went on a different path is is
a guy in that documentary
was a tough fighter you know hard worker
but just couldn't see he could have done
it he could have been there he could
have made money he could have been a
world champion he could have just
couldn't seem to pull it all together
and be consistent and and i saw him go
down a different road you know but he
had what it took
when you say different road what do you
mean he couldn't put it all together
meaning he couldn't stay disciplined was
it the association was it he couldn't
get rid of the bad friends was it
all of that all of them all of those
things
is is there a is there a uh when i'm
talking to mike and i'm saying hey he
says you know when mike tyson talks
about the fact that my son says he wants
to be a boxer i said what do you mean
you want to be a boxer you live in a
multi-million dollar house you don't
have what it takes to be a boxer what
are you talking about go back to school
i didn't grow up going to private school
you do right like he has a conversation
with his son do you see
a
common
trend with guys who end up becoming
killers in your world do they have
similar upbringing like do you see a
trend with that yeah i i think from my
point of view too it's
there's not a lot of people who
fight just because they want to fight
you know this fighting is scary it's uh
nerve-wracking it's dangerous there are
people out there obviously
who who do it and can be successful but
most of the time fighters are
you're fighting because you have to
you're fighting your way out of
something fighting for your family to
have a better you know
way of life you're fighting just to make
a name for yourself
so a lot of these guys in these gyms
that i've noticed are guys from similar
backgrounds you know made some bad
mistakes
found a way to that they can work with
their hands and and
and make a name for themselves you know
all these guys are blue collar hard
workers for the most part and um
they they didn't have a choice they
fought their way you know literally
uh into a better life and i see that
across the board whether it's boxing or
mixed martial arts
you don't it's not like you're playing
football and you you need pads and a
helmet and all you need to do is wake up
and have
hands and and you can shadow box you can
go for a run you can start working on
skills you don't need a lot of equipment
a pair of gloves
and and you're you're on your way to
start training and i just think
that too is part of people um
you know you don't need a lot of money
to start learning how to fight
so there's an edge to the blue collar
mentality
right you have to big edge when you're
coming up you don't have anything you're
around you know you're in the streets
you see stuff that others are not going
to see it's almost like the survival the
fittest type of deal right and you can
and it's something special because you
can literally
fight your way out of
whatever
you know life has has whatever hand
you've been dealt you can literally
fight your way punch by punch into a
better life yeah do you have any kids i
have one daughter how are you going to
pass that down to your kids
how do you pass down the blue collar
mentality so that's the thing you just
said like your buddy lives in a
multi-million dollar house i don't want
my daughter to fight you know i don't
want to see my daughter well are you
guys planning on having more kids yeah
okay so let's just say you have a son
like you how do you pass it down to him
i'd rather him go to go to college and
but uh
we'll see what happens i'll never tell
like try to direct them away from it but
i don't want to see that i i
but i will try to pass on the lessons
i've learned through fighting because
i've learned so much about myself um
through victory through losses through
business and i've been in rooms that i
would have never been in sitting across
from from people i would never be in
front of
if i never put on a pair of boxing
gloves so i'm thankful for that that's
cool it's kind of me and so so your kids
if your son says that i want to be like
you when i grow up i want to do ufc i
want to do mma what do you tell the kid
i'm not sure man i uh
take it one day at a time we'll take it
one day at a time so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]